There are two special cases we need to look at
while finding the 'HCF' and 'LCM' of two numbers.
First case, when one number is a multiple of the other.
And second, when they have no common factors except one.
Which means they are co-prime.
Let's understand the cases in detail.
The first case would have numbers like
four and eight, eight is a multiple of four.
Or numbers like 21 and 7, 21 is a multiple of seven.
One number is a multiple of the other.
Why is it a special case? It's because in such cases
the 'LCM' is always the greater number.
The 'LCM' of four and eight will be eight.
And the 'LCM' of 21 and 7, will be 21.
And the 'HCF' will always be the smaller number.
The 'HCF' of these two numbers will be 4.
And the 'HCF' of these two numbers will be 7.
What about the second case ?
An example of two co-prime numbers, would be 4 and 7.
Or 3 & 5.
Both these pairs have no common factors except one.
What is so special about 'LCM' and 'HCF' of such numbers?
Well the 'LCM' of such numbers,
will always equal the product of the two numbers.
For the first pair, the 'LCM' will be 4 times 7 which equals 28.
And for the second pair, the 'LCM' will equal 3 times 5, which equals 15.
And what will be the 'HCF' of such numbers?
It will always be 1.
The HCF of 4 and 7, as well as the HCF of 3 and 5, equals 1.
But remember,
these techniques should be used only to verify your answers.